Across series, galaxies, and generations,
one question has been left fairly
open-ended in the Star Trek franchise.
After over a half-century's worth of series
and films, we may finally have an answer.
Starfleet has its fair share of heroes — but
unfortunately, few admirals fall into that
category. Achieving a high rank in the Federation
might be a major reward for the intergalactic
explorers, but the price of having such a
powerful role has corrupted more than one leader.
Viewers have long argued about these leaders
and their various levels of failure. With
the popularity of Star Trek: Picard seemingly
reinvigorating the franchise, it only makes sense
that the discussion is popping up once again. Many
have questioned what causes admirals to go bad,
and this discourse has opened up a theory that has
long followed the franchise across various series.
After the original series,
its follow-ups, Star Trek:
The Next Generation and Star Trek: Deep Space
Nine, began to explore the darker side of power,
using admirals as a catalyst
for some pretty bleak plotlines.
In Star Trek: The Next Generation in particular,
it seems that the admirals are really only there
to bother crew members, specifically captains.
Despite Picard's loyal service to Starfleet,
they constantly question the captain's choices.
For someone who has been entrusted to run the
Enterprise, it's surprising how little
faith Starfleet's leaders have in him.
It's hard to overlook "The Drumhead"
when bringing up questionable admirals,
where a dilithium chamber explosion leads
to accusations of sabotage. In response,
a retired admiral — Norah Satie heads up an
investigation on the Enterprise. The crew
discovers it was not a deliberate act,
but Satie refuses to stop her pursuit.
Her eventual questioning of even
Picard himself leads to a tribunal,
and the entire storyline exposes a fear, hatred,
and paranoia that continues to be relevant in
today's society. Seeing Satie confronted
with the words of her father provides a
powerful rebuttal to such loathsome qualities
and shows how important it is to stop them.
"The first speech censured,
the first thought forbidden, the first
freedom denied chains us all irrevocably."
In turn, Deep Space Nine offered Admiral Ross,
whose motives have led to healthy debates among
fans. One Redditor praised Ross for not occupying
the archetypal, quote, "Starfleet Badmiral," role
in the series, while others were able
to identify acts like allying himself
to the morally ambiguous Section 31 as fairly
destructive, even if it benefited Starfleet.
The Star Trek franchise crossed over into adult
animation with the series Star Trek: Lower Decks.
It follows crew members of the ship Cerritos,
giving them an unprecedented active voice. In
many live-action series, these characters
would have been relegated to the background
or completely unseen in many cases, providing
a unique perspective on Starfleet goings on.
Tackling overlooked details also gave
the series a chance to reflect on why
admirals often turn bad. In one episode, Vice
Admiral Buenamigo even talks about reaching
the coveted level and demystifies
its importance. According to him,
the lack of a reason to push forward sends
seemingly ethical leaders on the wrong path.
"Star Fleet is so competitive.
Once you're an admiral, you hit a wall. I've
been trying for years to make a name for myself”
It doesn't hurt that Star Trek has often
explored the idea of admirals gone bad.
The Season 3 finale of Lower Decks featured
Buenamigo coming to terms with his own decisions;
an idea of AI in place of the Starfleet
crew may have seemed like a good idea
to Buenamigo at one point, but it
soon proved to be a deadly decision.
Much like Picard and Admiral Satie,
the choice of efficiency over actual
crew experience and empathy touches
on an unfortunate pattern: higher
ranking officials demeaning or overlooking the
contributions of lower ranked Starfleet members.